well bill thanks for being here like a
lot of people i
i love your uh your al pacino impression
when did you first do that impression
um i used to i did stand up for a little
bit in la
and i used to i used to do it and it was
al pacino giving a speech uh to a film
crew
on the first day before the first shot
to sort of inspire them
fire them and he was like um
i love film
i love women i love wine
i love kangaroos hey why not
[Laughter]
have you met why not
[Applause]
have you ever uh have you ever met uh al
pacino no i've never met him but i heard
that
he he had seen it like his agent had
come up to me and said i saw it i was
like oh
what are you oh you must be scared yeah
yeah i kind of freaked out that i was
gonna
you know come at my door or something
like open up oh yes
i'm here come on baby
but supposedly he said uh it's good
that has happened to me before
and i was like all right that's nice oh
thanks now on starting out live
uh you know i i worked there a long time
ago back before it was a television show
the thing that struck me i was a writer
there was people had no
idea people that just watched the show
and aren't backstage would have no idea
how last minute some of it oh yeah
you know writers uh performers are
coming up with bits sometimes like
uh you know an hour to just before the
the show is on the air
what's have you ever had to come up with
an impression kind of at the last minute
oh totally yeah i
we did uh the matthew fox show and i
showed up on friday
and midway through the day one of the
writers came up to me and said oh you're
doing kramer in the monologue
and i went oh yeah and you didn't do
it you never know or whatever and so
yeah you just have to like you get dvds
you go in your dressing room and you
like freak out over it and i kind of
figured out the hook on it which was uh
let me tell you jerry that is a really
nice suit
come up with an impression that you
liked but it's completely useless
there's no application
for it in the sketch comedy world or
really for anything
i i i figured i could do a tauntaun
which is a creature from star wars
you're a you're a big star wars fan i'm
a huge star wars fan
and i don't know if anybody yeah there
you go okay there's one and now
episodes four through six right not the
new one there's one and then everyone
else is pretending
one person was like yeah i'm gonna get
in on this
this star wars thing seems to be pretty
big i don't know what it is
uh no it was um what's that
is a creature uh from empire strikes
back uh that is a um
uh that luke skywalker and han solo used
to ride in the land of hoth which is an
ice planet uh
and i'm trying to figure out how to fit
it into a sketch yeah and the taunton is
basically i had to i'm
gonna use the chantan's basically um
[Music]
very good